Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 20th,
2017.
What's going on?
How,
why?
Yeah,
I am a recording off of my laptop.
If this sounds a little bizarre.
Um,
I'm in New York City,
came in town to do the,
uh,
the Patrice O'Neal benefit the fifth annual Patrice O'Neal benefit.
MMM.
It's going to be going down tomorrow night at the New York City Center.
And uh,
it should be a great time.
As you can tell.
I'm a little jet lagged.
I took a fucking red eye last night and there was this lady know what's
hilarious is when you have a kid,
if you actually go on the road,
the big thing when you go on the road now is not,
you know,
not the booze,
not the cigars,
not hanging out with your friends.
It becomes like,
Holy Shit,
I'm going to get eight hours of uninterrupted sleep.
So I get on the plane
and um,
this woman,
not in my row,
but the next row over,
she had a little baby and it was crying
and the dude next to me fell asleep and start snoring.
And,
uh,
I just started laughing.
And,
um,
the,
the poor woman,
like she was traveling alone with this baby.
Right.
And [inaudible] was a baby too,
maybe a little bit older than mine.
I,
I don't,
I'm,
this is my first kid,
so I can't judge.
I don't know if this kid was two,
three months,
I don't know if it was 26 years old and had that disease,
that dead fucking baby head in the Brad Pitt movie.
Remember that?
Remember the old baby was just hanging around and um,
you know,
that guy wanted to like bang the check and he's like,
you got to get this old baby outta here cause it's weird me out.
Which,
you know,
I'd like to think that that guy later on,
once his dick wasn't hard and he was thinking clearly again,
he probably was thinking,
you know,
I probably shouldn't have said that.
You know,
I probably shouldn't have trashed that old baby.
It was a name of a band.
I used to play an old baby and a,
you know,
we've got,
we've got a record contract and everything,
but uh,
you know,
please sing a gun,
an appendicitis.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Um,
anyway,
so the baby's fucking crying and the poor woman,
like she falls asleep in the baby's like freaking out screaming and she can't
hear it because she's like,
she's fucking exhausted.
She's got a baby and she's flying with it.
So,
and I'm sitting there and I'm watching the things squirming around in her hands
or like not really holding it anymore.
So now it's like this situation,
like,
is this,
is this lady gonna drop that fucking baby?
So I'm staring over there.
I'm sure other people will look at me thinking I was given her the evil eye
because the baby was crying,
but I wasn't,
I was just,
I dunno what the fuck I thought it was going to do,
cause I still had my seatbelt on.
Okay.
My safety first,
then have babies.
See that?
That's why I'll never be a hero.
Because what a true hero does is he sees danger and without any sort of self and
he's,
and he's safe.
You know what I mean?
That's to me is a year off.
Like if you're,
if you're in a fucking bank,
right?
And these guys come in with guns and they go to rob the place and they said,
we're going to blow everybody's fucking brains out and then you act on that.
You're not really a hero to me.
Okay?
Because at no point in that scenario where you safe,
all right,
you will immediately in the situation.
So no matter how you slice it,
no matter how many fucking people you say that the end of the day you were
motivated to save your own ass and everybody else getting saved along with you
is uh,
you know,
that's just collateral damage that makes positive.
But if you're outside the bag,
you're like,
Holy Shit,
I'm out here.
I mean,
you're begging bacon,
egg and cheese sandwich.
You know,
getting ready to go for a run,
you know,
fuel myself up.
Okay,
you stretching your fucking ham.
He said,
all of a sudden you see you,
I don't know if you look at one of those fucking giant bank windows,
you see a robbery going down and then you go in there with you Larry Bird short
shorts.
Right.
And fucking try to stop the rob dead to me.
Yeah.
That's like you what I mean you don't like,
there's like the hall of fame and then there's also,
you know,
people will literally have like their own wing of a hall of fame.
Yeah.
To me that's like,
yeah.
You know,
that's when you get your own way.
But if you're already in the shit,
I don't,
can't remember what the fuck I was talking about.
The honest with,
yeah.
Okay.
Not a hero.
Right.
So,
okay.
I finally sort of flagged down the stewardess and she goes,
yes,
you know what can I get you?
And I said,
I think what I have to fuck that I say,
I said,
can that baby fall?
And she started laughing.
Okay.
Cause she thought I was being sarcastic.
Like,
I was upset with the baby crying and she thought I meant like in that baby fall
on the ground and shut the fuck up.
And she was like taken aback.
But she also laughed,
which to me immediately made a really cool that she could laugh,
thinking that some guy was just being sarcastic,
being like,
in that baby,
please fall on the fucking floor of an airplane.
Knock itself out so I can get some sleep.
And I was like,
no,
no.
I,
I mean,
I was,
I'm concerned that it's going to fall.
So she kind of went over there to make sure the baby was all right.
But,
um,
okay.
I don't know.
I'm a changed man.
My urge was to go over and hold the baby.
What's happened to me becoming a fucking softy?
You know?
I actually know,
I told you before,
I never got mad at baby's crying on airplanes because I always felt they would,
they would just expressing exactly what I was feeling.
MMM.
There's no way to get on an airplane.
And at some point,
you know,
and unless you go in on some fucking great vacation,
but if you getting on there and you know you're going back to see the relatives
or some business trip or something like that,
you know,
and you just see some wide body coming down the fucking aisle and you're praying
to God,
the person is not going to sit next to you.
And we,
you know,
they got to,
something's going to fucking happen.
MMM.
It probably be really good for you,
for your life expectancy.
If you had access to your emotions that you could just break down crying.
Uh,
God,
I would love to ski mentioned,
get up on a fucking plane and it was just the 300 adults in there just crying
like babies.
Yeah,
I'd probably be a nightmare.
But then there's a part of me would think that that was awesome.
Anyways,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
So I,
um,
I'm telling this fucking story in the wrong way.
I actually,
yesterday I did a,
I presented at a Hollywood award shelf,
old freckles,
the big fucking phony himself.
Um,
when all Hollywood rented a Tuxedo shout out to Miss Detox on Wilshire
Boulevard,
mmm.
Wasn't going to say.
Yeah,
I had to,
uh,
had to do the present thing and I just sort of wrote something
and I quickly,
when I got to the writer's guild thing,
I immediately was like,
wow,
I should have not just written what I'm going to say once.
I should've gone over this a bunch of times.
So I just was kind of going over it in my fucking head.
And um,
you know,
I thought it was just going to be a bunch of writers,
but there was some like actors there and shit,
like Denzel was there and uh,
uh,
who's the other guy that,
James Woods,
it was a like,
I don't know,
there was like serious fucking people that,
the thing was when you go up in front of a bunch of writers,
like no matter what they've accomplished,
you don't know what they look like.
So you can't get nervous.
Like someone could literally have been sitting there and they wrote the best
picture Oscar winner fucking nine years in a row.
What,
nine years?
I know what they look like,
but whatever,
you know,
they could accomplish shit like that.
You have no fucking idea who they like for the whole night.
They would just pulling people out of the crowd and I will be sitting there
going,
I don't,
I don't know who this guy is.
And then when they would say what the fuck they did,
I was like,
Jesus Christ.
MMM.
So with every person they pulled out of the crowd,
like I dunno,
I just felt like the pressure was getting more and more and I just kept
muttering to myself,
this is it.
This is it one and done.
I'm never doing one of these fucking things again.
This is not,
this is not my,
uh,
this is not my thing.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing here.
This is stupid.
These people are,
are smart.
They're accomplished.
Like,
like the shit that,
you know,
some of the fucking people in the crowd,
the stuff that they do,
you know,
what it takes to write a movie and actually get it made and then get that
fucking giant rock up the fucking hill as opposed to me who just,
hey,
here's a tip,
a shit job.
I think we'll try this.
You know,
as I'm riding over on the subway to a club,
mmm.
I Dunno.
It just kept getting bigger and bigger and bigger and a Patton Oswald hosted it,
fucking murdered.
It's monologue was great.
Uh,
is Mandala was so great.
I kind of forgot that I had to go up.
I was just sitting there,
was a fan enjoying for an arborist,
was there and he went out and somehow gave his credit card information.
That's what he did before he said the nominees.
And somehow we made that fucking hilarious.
And once again,
it just made me feel like,
why am I here?
I shouldn't be here.
So I'm finally waiting to go up
and I'm,
James Woods is giving some sort of lifetime achievement award to a all over
stone.
Thank God this shit wasn't televised.
MMM.
Which is also fucking,
somebody made a reference to that.
Like nobody works fucking harder than those guys and they want to go and put it
on TV because nobody knows what they look like,
I guess.
MMM.
So he tells the whole fucking story of being best friends with Oliver Stone.
Yeah.
For 35 years and I have to go on after the shit and I just,
yeah.
That's why I just kept thinking.
I just kids,
I started looking at my watch.
The way I used to back in the day when I would do newness,
which is a standup expression for basically you're doing a college gig and the
show is essentially at 12 noon or one in the afternoon.
It's usually in a cafeteria and it is a fucking nightmare.
You go up there and you have to do an hour and you have to stand in front of
you.
Just stand in public in a cat fucking college cafeteria in front of like God
knows how many,
three,
four,
five,
600 fucking college students who have no idea
there's going to be any sort of performance.
Forget about a comedy show
and um,
like the,
the level of just fucking like,
I don't even,
I think it's like,
it's really hard for me to be humiliated now after doing enough of those.
Like you just get so walled off,
you just,
you just accept it.
You like,
okay,
my life is going to suck.
Like it's never sucked.
MMM.
Starting in about three minutes.
However,
in an hour,
in three minutes I'm going to be back in my rental car and I'm never going to
see these fucking again.
That's what,
that's what I,
that's the mindset I used to go into.
I used to go up there and I used to just psych myself up to be like,
how hard can I commit to these jokes?
How big of an ask can I make of myself?
And
just to try and to not give into the horror slash negative vibe of the
situation.
Because if he did that,
I learned the hard way.
You were going to burn through an hour of material in like 17 minutes and you
are going to be angry and um,
your agent was going to get a call.
Um,
so anyways,
James Woods is going on and on and on and he brings up fuck it.
And I don't mean that in a bad way.
It's just said,
um,
Oliver stone is accomplished so many things and all of this stone goes up there
and after a night of fucking Trump bashing,
just so eloquently stated that all the countries we've invaded,
all of the stuff that we've done.
And he said during all of our history of doing this,
there's been both Democrats and Republicans holding the office of President.
I thought I should have got more of an applause break,
but um,
you know,
I don't know.
The Trump thing is just such low hanging fruit.
At some point it's like we get it.
Hollywood does not like Trump.
Having said that,
this fucking guy went on stage and did the best Trump,
I should've gotten his name.
I was so fucking nervous.
But what I had to do,
he did the best Trump impression,
I the fucking nuance performance that he did.
Uh,
it just,
it was unbelievable.
And then he did a lot of really,
really fucking harsh jokes.
Like even like writers,
they sit and fucking writer's room.
You wouldn't think that you'd get them to pull back.
It's just cause they were in public.
Um,
and he just totally fucking committed.
So I got kind of inspired by that.
So long story short,
I'm sitting there waiting to go on.
And uh,
they mentioned that Oliver Stone,
I guess wrote Scarface,
which I didn't know.
And I remember my mother took us to go see that my youngest brother was nine at
the time.
So I thought that was pretty cool.
So I just went out there and I sort of winged it,
told a story about how I used to think of pony was a small horse.
And,
and I don't even,
I can't remember what I said,
but I think it went okay.
And,
um,
I got off stage and I actually thought for half a second,
like,
you know what,
that was actually kind of fun.
And I realized that a lot of buy adversion to award shows is just my own social
anxiety of not knowing how to behave when there's a room full of people just
saying positive shit to each other.
Like if that they'll give award shows were like absolute,
I'm not talking like roast.
Okay.
I don't like row seeder.
I don't know what happened to roasts roast to me used to be funny.
And then it just became just like this,
you know,
Tourette's thing.
Hey,
I wouldn't fuck you with a dog.
Dick AIDS Cock Shit cunt.
You know,
it's just like,
all right,
so and so's there,
I'm not saying any,
we'll go,
we'll go.
But this Guy Bob and dub a doable,
I'd find them fucking mind.
Numbingly boring.
MMM.
But whatever is somewhere in between this somewhat,
somewhere short of that.
MMM.
If it was totally negative,
I would have been comfortable.
So I don't,
what the fuck that says about me.
So I figured out what my hangup was with WWE.
I will say though,
um,
I still will never get past listening to fucking people talk politics in
fucking,
uh,
the environmental issues.
Okay.
In all of that shit,
it's just like everybody knows we already know this shit.
Okay.
We already know it.
You're not going to inspire anybody.
Like,
you know,
I kind of gave a shit about the environment,
but then when that guy from fucking a third rock from the sun set that shit
about Antarctica,
I was like,
wait a minute,
this is an important issue.
Uh,
I dunno,
maybe I'm just a negative con why am a negative comp?
But I'll never be able to get,
I just,
I just think that's just like some,
like
it's like the Beyonce thing,
you know what I mean?
Like I never would've thought that somebody could like
exaggerate the magnitude of creating life,
but somehow she's done it.
My wife gets so upset when I make,
I don't,
I mean,
I don't really have any feelings.
It's just fun to make fun of her.
It's her fan base is just so fucking,
I dunno.
I was like,
I was driving me nuts when she was watching the grammys and stuff.
Like I,
first of all,
I don't get,
why does she get like a four hour performance and everybody else only gets like
fucking six seconds.
Okay.
You know,
brewer,
Bruno Mars is running around and doing a bunch of costume changes.
You know,
she comes out dressed like a Batman villain in fuck.
It does like a 45 minutes set.
I would think it was fair to the other performance,
but you know what,
I gotta be honest with you.
I don't think I could name one.
Wow.
Ooh,
delicious.
That was a,
that's when she was with those other two girls that she kicked to the curb.
I,
if you're in an all girl group or if you're in a boy band,
you can't at this point,
people have to be so fucking educated that you know,
at some point there's going to be,
yeah.
Like one person is going to go solo,
you know,
it'd be extremely successful in the rest of you are just going to be sitting
around working at staples,
hoping that the person who left and is now wildly successful.
A solo artist will eventually have a couple of shit album.
So they have to come back to you to do a reunion tour.
You know what I mean?
Like,
do you think Justin Timberlake's ever going to do the instinct thing?
Maybe he has.
I don't fucking know.
Uh,
well I could say,
I guess what I'm saying is if I was in a boy band way back in the day and I
still had my reddish orange hair,
mmm.
I would save my money.
I'd be like,
you know what?
Someone's going to break out.
I know it's not going to be making,
oh,
well.
Um,
anyways,
how far into this podcast already?
I gotta check.
I gotta check the fucking time.
MMM.
Hey,
how about fucking ah,
the Boston Bruins?
We were,
we are undefeated with our new coats coach.
I don't even know what it was in Bruce Cassidy,
a butch Cassidy and the Sundance kid.
I already forgot his fucking name.
I've been some goddamn busy.
Um,
hey.
You know what the best thing about having a baby is,
dude,
you can watch so much fucking sports in the first three months before they learn
how to crawl around and shit.
Every morning.
My faith,
like my daughter is like my new best friend.
I mean,
I was going to happen anyway.
Sorry for the extra noise.
So sending the laptop down.
My daughters,
my new best friend.
Okay.
Aside from the obvious that she's my blood,
she's my daughter and everything,
but just like on a real level,
she's my best friend.
I probably have watched like 20 games with her already every morning.
Right.
The lovely Nia,
you know,
she's exhausted cause she still has to breastfeed at night.
Well I just have to wake up,
you know,
and change a diaper every once in a while.
Sorry for the hiccups here.
So in the mornings I try to give my wife like three hours at least.
You know what I mean?
Like I got it down where if she just feeds or I can take her and then I can have
an inch.
And you know,
I have a,
I have like,
I have a little fucking bottle,
you know,
to feed her.
I can,
I can go three hours.
I can keep her calm for fucking three hours while,
uh,
my wife sleeps and all that type of stuff.
So what I do is I just tape games and every morning we come upstairs and I just
put her on my chest and I just sit there and I watch games with her.
And um,
when she starts to cry,
you know what it is.
It was a,
what's been working for me,
you know,
those giant exercise balls that people use for core strengths.
I just get on one of those and I just,
just fucking bouncing up and down on the thing.
It gives them the feeling of weightlessness is some shit.
And if they start crying when you're doing the bouncing thing,
cause it's killing my fucking back,
right.
I just go fucking crazy big air.
Then they just like,
you know,
it makes them almost almost like when a dog wants to kill somebody and if you
make a loud enough noise and they fucking looks at the in another direction,
it just,
they completely forget that they wanted to kill somebody.
Babies are like that.
Or if they start to cry,
if you get this stomach to drop,
they kind of go make this face like,
well,
you know,
their eyes get big and shit and then they just kind of get into that vibe and
then you slow.
You just slowly get it back down to three,
four repetitions back down to the lob level that you have and they don't cry.
And,
um,
that eventually they fall asleep.
Then I do,
you know,
that I got to,
I got the fucking game on and um,
I've watched more fucking college who said it's going to that Duke UNC game.
I've been,
you know,
obviously started taping all the Duke Games.
Um,
I watched Duke,
Virginia,
I missed them against wake forest yesterday,
but,
uh,
I got all the rest of the year.
I think they got like,
they got Syracuse on Wednesday,
then they got university in Miami and then a Florida state.
And then they play UNC again March 4th.
Even if you're,
you're not a huge fan of fucking college basketball.
You've got to watch that one.
I watched Kentucky,
Georgia,
so Georgia,
you lose another heartbreaker I watched Wisconsin,
Maryland,
which was fucking so boring.
I went into my fucking DVR and I had tape,
UNC,
Virginia,
and I watched that one instead.
And once that a fucking kid,
what's his name?
Number 44 when UNC,
the fuck is his name.
It's a literation Justin Jamieson.
No,
I can't remember his fucking name.
I'm,
I fucking sleep deprived here.
Um,
totally gotten into that.
I've been watching the NHL and because of the all star break,
you know,
the Celtics gave me a break,
cause they,
they,
they were on the all star break and I got to watch a bunch of college shit.
So anyways,
um,
I landed here in New York,
slept the whole fucking flight.
I had my eye mask in my earplugs and I was all good.
That lady didn't drop dead baby and um,
everything was fine,
you know,
nobody tried to hijack the plane,
everything was good and I get in the car taking the cab ride over to the hotel
and uh,
they had Trump on the radio and it's just a fucking guy met Jesus Christ.
He was talking about some terrorist thing that happened in Sweden.
He goes,
I mean this happened in Sweden.
People Sweeney,
he yells sweet.
And again he just saw like,
I just,
I cannot fucking believe,
I can't believe that this guy is president and I cannot believe that he's,
he's so successful at it in that he's just implementing everything.
Like I didn't know you could just go around Congress with these fucking
executive orders.
Man is fucking hilarious that he's filed yet another,
this guy is like the,
if there's like a hall of fame for filing the loophole,
I mean he really is like a,
he's a fucking genius.
I just wish he was more stable because,
um,
you know,
Hillary would have scared the shit out of me and a much quieter,
dignified way and not even dignified just as far as she knows how to give a
fucking speech.
But,
um,
I dunno,
the day he stops reacting to people saying shit about them in award shows,
I think I'll feel a little more comfortable with the fact that he's,
uh,
you know,
in power,
this is like the most simple and basic thought I've ever had in my life,
right.
Is they keep talking about how the tensions,
you know,
bit of Russia was actually in communication with Trump in Europe,
all nervous because,
uh,
Russia's fucking doing whatever over there and blah,
blah,
blah.
And these guys are thinking this and these guys are thinking that.
And I just was thinking like,
hey,
why doesn't everybody just fucking relax?
You know?
And I don't mean you,
I don't mean me.
We just regular,
everybody's just walking around,
you know,
living your life,
getting a fucking newspaper.
Why don't these kinds up top,
why don't you just fucking relax?
I know this is way too overly simplified,
but like I would have no fucking idea what another country was thinking or
planning to do if you weren't yammering about it.
All right?
And if the other people on the other side weren't yammering about,
what the fuck we're trying to do?
You know,
why don't we just stay?
Everybody just stays home.
Where's your country?
You fucking stay there,
right?
I don't mean refugees.
I just mean leaders in your arms.
Just fucking stay there.
We bring our guys back.
Everybody just sorts out their own shit.
You know?
And when people come to your country to go to your fucking water park or
whatever,
you'd give them the Mickey mouse ears.
You give them,
do you get to be put on a show?
Well why can't it just fucking be like the,
you know why?
Cause they want to get the fucking,
you know,
natural resources and money.
That's all the fuck it is.
That's all it is.
I don't give a fuck of all any of that goddamn rhetoric.
That's why the fuck they ain't doing it.
And all they do is sit there scaring the shit.
I,
I just wish everybody could like regular people just collectively all at the
same time be like and fuck it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
Fuck it.
Fuck everything is saying fuck wars.
Fuck all of this shit.
If you fucking rich concept have a problem with each other,
why don't you sit down at your yacht clubs and try and fucking work it out?
You know,
play a game of seven,
seven fucking something,
stud,
whatever the final one card play,
whatever the fuck it is he do you know enough with the blowing up of people and
shit.
I don't know.
I know it's completely over simplified but Nike at sometime.
But when I think about having mind control,
like that's what I think of doing.
I haven't,
you know,
we'd like people on the terrorist groups all the way to our country starts
saying we're going to go to war.
It's just like,
yeah,
no,
you know now not all righty then and then just see what the fuck they would do.
I think they would literally lose their fucking minds.
They wouldn't know what to do because they'd just be like,
well,
now what?
What am I going to do?
And if I'm not out there trying to get more,
what am I going to do?
Sit here alone with my own thoughts.
How many do you think would actually take their own lives?
Like take that fatty over there in North Korea?
I'm really in over my head.
By the way,
if you haven't realized that this is like meet the press with no press or
information,
it's the same thing.
I'll probably get sued by that program for a
ruining their format.
Um,
that fat cunt there,
you know,
old softy there.
It doesn't have a whisker on his fucking face.
Like,
you know what I mean?
Like you want to be able to grow a fucking crazy beard man.
You know that,
that,
that's one thing I'll have to commend that.
I don't even know his name.
Kim Jong Il,
is that his name?
Was it Kim Jong Il Jr Sonny boy.
Um,
Frank Sinatra jr whatever the fuck his name is over there.
Like the fact that he can't grow a beard and he still has people scared
shitless.
You know,
like what if they could just collectively over there,
everybody just be like,
yeah,
dude,
we don't give a fuck anymore.
Right.
And everybody just goes about their business.
He still gets to live in that big fucking house,
but nobody listens to him.
Like how like nobody will kill farm anymore.
No Army.
We'll do anything.
But he still gets to keep the giant fucking house.
Like how fucking freaked out when he'd be,
you know,
nobody really goes over and talks to him or anything.
So eventually he has to come out and go to like a farmer's market,
you know,
and then you don't talk to them.
You force him to acclimate himself socially.
You know,
like anybody else would if they were the new guy in town.
If I had mind control,
that's what the fuck I went to.
Um,
what I,
I don't know what do I,
I would probably do some evil shit.
He can't,
even if you could control the entire world's fucking brains.
Yeah.
I don't think,
I
don't think I can handle that power.
I fuck that.
I,
that was a dumb idea.
All right,
let's,
let's read some,
uh,
let's read some fucking,
advertising here for this week.
All right.
Uh,
wince pronounced the Winc spelled [inaudible] without the Ewi.
NC.
Okay.
All right.
With see India,
November Charlie,
finding new.
Great new wine is tough.
You know,
I can tell you I've got to agree with these.
I got agree with these fucking people.
That to said constantly.
I know they don't like when I say that during these reads,
I actually agree with these guys.
Finding good wine is difficult.
It's like trying to find a good cigar.
Like where the fuck do you start?
There's so many of them.
There's so many articles.
There's so much fake news.
Fake news about the cigars.
I'm finding new one is tough.
That's why I've been telling you all about our sponsor,
a club,
w column,
JB,
Atlanta,
not present anymore.
I'd fly fish and paint and how they make it so easy to get wine personalized to
your palate and delivered right to your door.
And here's a little update free for you.
Club w is now called wince,
spelled or called Winc,
spelled w.
I.
N.
C.
A new name and an improved look.
But here's the important part.
It's still the same amazing wine company introducing you to new wines that you
love.
Why did they switch from club w to something that you,
it's really difficult to pronounce and spell winked works directly.
It's not,
I'm not saying it's difficult to pronounce,
but like if you looked at w I n C I mean you're not thinking wink.
What does that stand for?
Okay.
We incorporate no of slope went works directly with wine makers and growers from
all over the world to create delicious wines and deliver it right to your door
weeks 100% satisfaction guarantee means if you don't like the bottle of a bottle
they send you,
they'll replace it with a bottle you love.
No questions asked.
Jesus Christ,
Ernest Hemingway,
born a hundred years too soon.
You don't get sent random bottles.
WINC is a personalized wine membership that recommends wine specifically for you
based on the results of your palate profile quiz.
I can't believe I'm such a drunk and I haven't,
you haven't fucking use this yet.
The great thing about drinking wine is you don't feel like a drunk.
You know,
you actually feel like you read a book or something.
You can also rate all of the wine you receive from Winc so they learn about you
with every order and constantly personalize the wine they send.
Sign up for Winc right now and gain immediate insider access to the best fine
wine from all over the world.
Find out for yourself why yours truly and thousands of other satisfied wine
lovers are raving about Winc while I'm doing it because you're paying me.
The best part.
Winc is offering my listeners $20 off right now.
When you go to try winc.com they'll even cover the shipping,
shipping,
shipping.
Think about that and you'll get fine wine personalized to your palate,
delivered right to your door.
Try Winc and get $20 off a complimentary shipping right now.
When you go to try winc.com has tried.
W I n c.com/bro,
why don't they have that with like whiskeys and scotches?
You know why?
Cause that's,
that's mean.
That's mean alcohol.
You know what I mean?
When you ship a bunch of wine
and what's going to happen,
you know
some woman's going to slur around some guy,
I'll start crying.
It's just wine,
right?
I hope this isn't making too much noise as I'm moving this thing around,
but like I can only sit in one position for so long.
It's part of it.
Yeah.
Are Getting
old.
All right.
Oh look who's here.
But to me,
Andy's me undies or the rug.
K.
So wine,
they do two to
me on these B and e's.
You pissed your pants but you fine because they have that fucking Modell's.
It'll dry up the grapes and you'll be a power when you take your nuts and your
dick out.
Yo,
I hope you drank some fucking white wine or your bulls will be purple.
Me undies.
Picture a picture.
A world we're putting on a new pair of underwear isn't just fresh.
You stepping into a better day.
So you've got to take a shower first.
You can't just put on a fresh pair of underwear,
you gotta take a shower,
then you put it on a fresh pair of underwear.
If you combine that with a fresh pair of socks telling you right now,
your energy is going to be crazy.
Like,
do you realize that there's,
there's women out there that married guys because the first time they met them,
they were wearing a fresh pair of underwear and socks and they just felt this
amazing energy from,
you know,
and then now they're stuck in this lovely loveless marriage,
wondering where it all went.
And what they have to understand is that like,
you know,
ladies,
if you,
if you want you guide to treat you nice.
Okay?
Every once in a while you got to go out.
You gotta make sure you update his fucking underwear and sock drawer.
They'll put them in a better mood.
You know what I mean?
You don't have to cower in the corner anymore.
All right?
Think about it.
Underwear.
It's the first thing you put on in the last thing you take off.
Unless you Matthew mcconaughey,
why would you settle for anything less than the best feeling underwear on the
planet?
Um,
you,
Andy's focuses solely on producing the most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced.
This is all they fucking do.
24,
seven.
My friends that in the Andes,
I don't know.
You sent me a few pairs awhile back and now I can't imagine wearing anything
else.
I where I wear,
I,
you only gave me fucking too.
Okay.
And I am a men over the age of 45,
which means I can't figure out the fucking Internet.
So even if I wanted to order some underwear,
which I desperately need to do,
most of my underwear is at least from two presidents ago.
Um,
I'm everything in this ad.
I'm the exact Carson that should be getting me undies.
Um,
evidently it really makes each day that much better for the price of two
cocktails me undies,
we'll deliver your new favorite pair of underwear right to your doorstep.
Better Day,
guaranteed you try them on.
If they're not the most comfortable,
best feeling uneasy had,
they'll refund you and let you keep your first pair for free.
Included in the price is this sweet touch of out,
why did they say sweet touch in your crotch area.
A special fabric made with the best in class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times softer than cotton.
He's Uber Cozy undies are sold exclusively on Mondays website.
While you enjoy free standard shipping in the US plus Canada,
uh,
and for a limited time,
everyone in my audience gets 20% off their first order.
But if you have,
but you have to go to our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burr with Dameon.
He's better day guarantee.
You have nothing to lose.
So no wait any longer.
Go to me on these.com/pro right now for 20% your first order.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash bar.
All right.
Oh fuck.
He likes everybody Hallux.
Your unique.
Oh God.
You don't walk like everyone else talk like everyone else is asleep like
everyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all well?
Because there's a basic shape of a fucking human being.
Not to mention his size because,
oh,
I'm sorry.
I guess I had the wrong answer because it truly customized mattress will cost
you five to 10,000 bucks until now.
Go to hell,
sleep.com and answer a few simple questions and they'll run a three d
biomechanical model of your body.
Yeah,
and then you'll show up in the next season of fucking Westworld through the
proprietary algorithms they developed with the help of the world's leading
ergonomics and biomechanics experts.
The result,
the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on.
Yeah,
I'd have it.
A robot made and your fucking image,
a hallux customers report at 30% improvement in overall sleep quality.
And for couples that customize each side of the mattress.
Okay.
Your mattress arrives at your door in about a week.
How to fucking,
they do this in a week and shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine to Forbes,
they're all talking about helic sleep.
You have a hundred nights to try it out.
And if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free grouse and give you a hundred a hundred percent
refund.
No questions asked.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar and get $50 off your order.
That's helix sleep.com/burr heloc sleep.com/bar
mmm.
All right.
Lastly,
but not leastly stamps.com avoid the hassle,
okay
of the post office and mailing everything from postcards to envelopes to
packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes online with no equipment to lease.
No longterm commitments.
Click print mail and you're done.
Unlike the post office stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your convenience.
24 seven seven days a week.
stamps.com brings all the services of the US Postal Service right to your
fingertips by in print official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer and printer stamps.com we'll even help
you decide the best class of mail based on your needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter.
I use stamps.com anytime of sending out my fucking posters,
you know,
whoring myself out.
And right now you can enjoy the stamps service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale with longterm
commitments.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburgerthatstamps.com enter
bar.
All right,
there we go.
Jesus Christ.
I'm done with that shit.
Sorry for setting them fucking laptop.
How much time will be up to here?
MMM.
Oh 38 minutes.
Perfect time to start reading some letters.
Before I do,
I want to thank everybody,
uh,
the night before the Patrice or only your benefit for everybody that has,
bought tickets once again.
Um,
and we've been able to keep this benefit going and I cannot even begin to tell
you how much this has helped his loved ones.
Um,
it's just been such a great thing and a is sad and tragic as it always will be
that he passed away too soon.
Um,
just all you guys stepping it up every year and seeing like just how much that
has changed,
uh,
and help the peoples that he was helping out when he was alive.
It's just I can't thank you enough.
All right.
Okay.
Uh,
Friday the 13th bullshit.
Oh,
this is,
um,
this is in regards to,
I was talking about that like why is Friday the 13th unlucky rather than Monday
the 13th.
So this person comes to me with this.
It says bill,
with regards to your podcast involving Friday the 13th,
the main superstition that spread was amongst sailors during the late 17th
century who considered setting sail on any Friday to be a bad omen.
And given that most people,
including pirates,
were God fearing Christians.
The 13,
the 13 relating to the last supper being the night before Jesus died according
to historical hearsay,
the 13 relating to the last supper,
the night before Jesus died where they're 13 upon,
there was 12 apostles plus Jesus.
That was 13.
Okay.
If the 13th fell on front,
well first of all,
I don't understand why didn't sailors wait until the 17 hundreds.
They waited 1700 years,
minus 32 years,
so they waited 1,600 and fucking 68 years.
People have been sailing for fucking ever.
They were sailing back in Jesus's Day.
Right?
Well,
I guess there was no fucking social media,
so it took a while for the story to get out.
I Dunno.
Anyways,
if the 13th fell on Friday,
most docs imports would be emptied out as sailors believe this to be the
greatest ill omen there could possibly be and for reason and reason enough not
to work on the day or get out of bed for that matter is most people of that time
hung crucifixes over their bed and believed it to be the safest place in the
house that I'm going to say most people didn't do that.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
I would just say like if back in the day,
if TV news existed,
those were the people's houses that they would go to and they would try to scare
the shit out of everybody about Friday the fucking 13th but I think they would.
I think that there was a lot of fucking people back then.
Even back then,
that were just like,
dude,
are you finding you a fucking
okay?
It was people back then that said,
Jesus Shit never happened.
They would say it's a couple of pieces of wood.
It makes the shape of a cross.
It's,
it's,
it's not like some holy fucking [inaudible] imagine there was plenty of people,
granted they probably got lit on fire if they said some shit like that.
I have no idea.
So anyways,
it sounds pretty basic now,
but back in the day,
people simply didn't know any better.
If you fell sick around a Friday,
you were unlucky around,
uh,
around a 13th of a month.
Also unlucky.
But the two together,
somehow it was much worse.
Dip Shit.
Ancestors.
Um,
oh,
they just lack the information.
Jesus Christ.
What about us?
We're the smart ones ruining the fucking oceans.
The Great Barrier Reef is dead.
You know,
they didn't fucking go.
They woulda killed it if they had the fucking opportunity.
You know what did the same dip shits we are right now.
All right.
Canadian,
uh,
bus be header.
Oh,
you know what,
I,
I meant to look this up.
So did you hear about this guy who beheaded and eight another guy and they set
free?
How the fuck is he allowed free and why wasn't he executed?
How do they know he won't relapse into another murder slash?
Dinner?
Am I crazy by saying if you murder someone,
you should be murdered yourself.
Um,
well yeah,
if,
if people didn't lie,
you know,
if there weren't people wrongly convicted,
I mean,
I just,
if I feel like though,
if it's beyond a shadow of a fucking doubt,
uh,
you know,
if you do something,
the animals kids or if you eat somebodies head on a bus,
I would have to say,
you know,
yeah,
he want to fucking,
you want to handle it?
Uh,
oh,
you don't,
I forgot the fucking,
before I get in this shit,
I forgot to hide my youtube page.
I'm finally going to start posting videos of them and start doing tours of
cities again.
And you can watch all of this on my youtube page.
www.youtube.com/user/monday morning podcast,
youtube.com/users/monday morning podcast.
Um,
all right,
let me,
let me try to find the link of this fucking guy,
Jesus Christ.
Fucking eating semi.
How you mean,
how would you even go about eating ahead?
MMM.
Oh,
this is a different one.
Wait a second.
Is it no link to this one?
What just happened here?
Oh,
I do have a link.
I'm sorry guys.
This is usually what I'll try to hit fucking pause so you don't have to go
through the torture of this.
All right,
Garrett is,
there it is.
Okay.
Here we go.
Canadian man who be headed bus passenger.
Granted total freedom.
Winnipeg,
Manitoba,
Aka winter pig,
homer the jets.
Um,
a Canadian man who was found not criminally responsible for beheading and
cannibalizing a fellow passenger on a Greyhound bus has been granted his
freedom.
He cut somebody's head off,
fucking aided and wasn't criminally responsible or who was
Manitoba's Criminal Code Review Board announced Friday.
It will give.
It is given.
Will Baker formerly known as Vince Sleep?
Well,
thanks for fucking up his identity.
MMM.
And an absolute discharge meeting.
He is no longer subject to monitoring
man who thought roommate was a Zombie pleads guilty to murder.
Okay.
What the fuck is going on in Canada?
That's a completely different story.
He's a rabbit hole.
I'll read that one.
Next.
Baker a diagnosed schizophrenia killed Tim Mclean,
a young carnival worker.
Jesus Christ.
See,
this is why you never take bosses,
Carney workers,
schizophrenia.
It's just you know,
you're taking your life in your hands.
A young carnival worker who was a complete stranger to Baker in 2008 a year
later,
he was found not criminally responsible due to mental illness.
Okay.
Mclean's mother,
Carol,
whatever has been outspoken against granting bakers for her or his own mother is
saying,
don't set this guy free saying there'd be no way to ensure he continued to take
his meds.
She declined.
Comment in a,
in a post on Facebook Fridays saying,
I have no words.
Baker was initially kept in a secure wing of a psychiatric hospital,
was given more freedom every year.
He's been living on his own and Winnipeg apartment since November,
but it was still subject to monitoring trait to ensure he took his medication.
Baker's Docker,
dude,
this is fucking insane.
You let a head eat go free.
MMM,
I dunno dude.
Do you think that they should kill people who are mentally insane?
I mean,
what are you going to do?
Are you going to stick them in a room and beat him?
For instance,
Flintstone vitamins for a select right.
Made him thought roommate was a Zombie pleads guilty to murder.
These are all just mentally ill people here,
man.
A 38 year old man who said he beat his roommate to death because he thought she
was a Zombie,
pleaded no contest.
The secondary murder.
Now I'm sitting there wondering,
maybe he just beat her to death and now he's just trying to act like he's
fucking insane.
Um,
guy entered the plea Friday,
ms strangling and beating death of 35 year old Jennifer Lopez.
Not the same.
I want to obviously,
uh,
cause the Kansas City Star reported Wallace told police he had fallen asleep
after taking a methamphetamine court.
Documents said he began beating Lopez when she woke up because he thought she
was a Zombie.
He told police he kept being Lopez until something made him stop.
Okay.
Wow.
This is not a funny podcast anymore.
Now is it,
um,
uh,
should you be murdered if you murder somebody?
I think without a fucking doubt,
if they know you did it.
Yeah.
MMM.
And uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I saw it.
I don't want to say what this fucking person did do a kid,
but the kid died and like,
I was just like,
why is that person still walking on the earth?
There's definitely times where I feel that,
and I don't think that that makes us as bad as they are.
MMM.
But prison is a big business,
so,
you know,
they want that fucking guy in a cell.
All right.
Ministry of truth.
Hey there,
Billy.
Hey Billy.
Of Rights.
Uh,
I'm sorry guys.
I'm so fucking jet lag to this podcast is really just fucking lagging here.
Dragging,
I should say.
Lots of people are comparing Trump to Hitler.
Okay.
Uh,
but back in December,
Obama tried to quietly pass a bill that would allow the government,
yeah,
I saw this have jurisdiction over news and outgoing information on all channels.
I.
E.
TV,
Internet,
radio.
That includes you.
You can read the fine print in the article below.
Also,
fuck all the people listening who haven't read the legislation but are,
uh,
already up in arms because it goes against who they cheer for.
Amen to that.
Everybody,
like,
like last night,
all these fucking guys at this fucking award show everybody trashing Donald
Trump,
nobody brings up the fact that Obama basically signed something that is going to
implement an incredible level of fucking censorship.
Like they're,
they're basically going to decide what is real news and what is fake news.
I mean,
I'd like to think,
because I openly admit that I don't read,
and the shit that I say is just fucking absurd that I would be exempt,
but who knows?
But like people with blue ties do this shit all the fucking time.
And that's,
that's what kills me about people who wear red ties and watch Fox News and the
Hollywood people.
Like they just cannot see the bullshit
all out of the only six.
It's like,
it's like listening to was a fanatic red sox and Yankees Fan.
You know what I mean?
You know,
giving each other shit for buying titles in fucking abusing steroids.
And it's like,
no,
we both did it.
We bought it.
We should hang our heads in shame collectively.
Um,
all right.
Let me see if I can find this.
This are,
I,
I don't really even want to fucking read this because this is just so fucking,
yeah.
Uh,
let's see.
So the AI have signed into law S.
Dot.
Two nine four three,
the National Defense Authorization Act for the fiscal year 2017 this act
authorizes fiscal year 2017 appropriations principally for the department of
Defense and the Department of energy national security programs provides vital
benefits for military personnel families.
Okay.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
And where do we get to the,
yeah.
Do I can't read all of this.
I can't read all of this.
I don't want to fucking,
this will take me fucking three hours to read out to this.
This would have to be a part of a,
a mini series for me to read all of this.
Okay?
Uh,
here's some Oh shit and bold.
The first priority is developing a whole of government strategy for countering
the foreign propaganda and disinformation being wage wage against us and our
allies by our enemies.
Now that reads great,
but it's basically,
you know,
they want to listen to our propaganda,
not their fucking propaganda.
You know,
our version of what's going on is right and their version is wrong.
We're all fallible.
We're all fucking human beings,
but we don't make mistakes.
They do.
So,
I dunno.
It just gets back to all of that shit.
And you know what?
Sorry,
you're never going to solve.
And even everybody's sin starts fucking screaming at each other.
And if you ever bring up something like that,
people call you a socialist and tell you to get the fuck out of the country.
If you,
if you would ever even remotely suggest that this government would ever fucking
lie,
they all lie to their fucking people.
Uh Oh God,
they'll shut up.
Okay dear Billy beer thighs.
Um,
forgive my poor English.
Well the fact that he can come up Billy Beard thighs in a fucking second
language is pretty amazing.
So I I think your English is fucking,
yeah,
great.
Um,
I am a native Berliner but I have family across Germany.
One of my female cousins was harassed on the way to work by some people who are
different.
I didn't want to s I do not want to say just a different race or religion,
but also a different way of thinking.
They are not native to Germany and are not acclimating well to western life.
I am not a racist and I find the issues very sensitive,
but I believe that reality has to play a part in one's objective view.
I'm not against refugees or anyone displaced because of terrible political and
military situations,
but also have a new opinion because of my cousin.
She is okay,
but had 19 stitches in the back of her neck and head from a bottle thrown at her
because she was a woman walking alone at night.
This is not the first time this has happened in her town.
MMM.
That was good enough to show good graces to refugees.
Uh,
if countries are going to let people in,
they have to at least be okay with women having certain rights.
Should they not forget about religion or release.
That's just good and bad.
Um,
I think am I a bad person for becoming a more cautious person when it comes to
refugees?
Thank you and cheers on your new child.
Uh,
no,
not at all.
I mean a lot of that and also people's prejudice because you're German,
they're going to fucking think a certain way.
But like,
you know,
if one of the elements that comes into play is that from wherever these other
people are from,
that a woman walking alone at night is suggesting that she's fucking,
I dunno,
I dunno what loose or having sex or whatever the fuck it is that's going to make
them throw a God damn bottle.
Like how do you not address that?
MMM.
And also to me it's like what kind of a fucking person,
you know,
when I go to another country,
like whatever I see,
I just go,
oh,
I guess that's how they do it over here.
I don't think like,
you know,
well,
I'm from someplace else and this is the way we do it.
So I'm going to act like we're still in my country.
I think that's ignorant,
but,
um,
never underestimate the power of religion.
You know,
when people really get into it,
when they really fucking get into it,
um,
I,
you know,
there's,
there's something where your brain goes on like autopilot and you just let
religion make decisions for you and rational thought kind of goes out the
fucking window and you just start breaking one commandment after another.
Like you tell me one religion out there,
if you could find it in whatever book it is that you read that say it's that
says it's fucking okay to throw a fucking bottle at a woman walking alone at
night.
I mean,
it shouldn't you give me an if you think it's,
you should have walked her home if you were concerned about like,
I dunno,
I don't understand.
Like,
um,
but yeah,
one of the things,
um,
I think refugees should,
like,
if I,
if okay,
say this,
this country goes to complete shit and there's a big war and all of a sudden
they're hunting down fucking bald redheads and I need to seek political asylum
or some shit in another country.
When I go there,
the first thing I'm going to do is try to learn the fucking language and then
I'm going to try to figure out,
okay,
how do they do shit over here?
You know what I mean?
So I don't fucking offend anybody and so I don't get the shit kicked out of me.
But I would say the type of people that throw a bottle like that,
um,
okay.
You know,
they're also the kind of people that if they were in a higher up in a corporate
thing that they would be a
pilfering the coffers as they say or whatever.
Like there's just certain people out there that just,
they're not good people.
There's certain people that are just not smart people.
Um,
that's one of the fucking problems with human beings is this,
a lot of mouth breathing morons.
And,
uh,
when you accept a bunch of refugees,
you know,
you're going to get some fucking super smart people all the way down to mouth
breathing morons.
Um,
I don't think you're,
yeah.
Why wouldn't you be more cautious when it came to refugee subs if something like
that happen?
I mean,
now having said that within your own country,
you also have neo Nazis.
You know what I mean?
So,
you know,
uh,
if you're suggesting getting rid of all refugees,
then you should also do something about Neo Nazi.
So,
um,
the hard fucking thing when people go to a new country is they don't look like
the people that are there.
So they stick out like a fucking sore thumb and people stopped looking at them
as human beings.
They just look at them and just one giant group.
Whereas if you look at a fucking neo Nazi,
he's still a fucking white dude.
I'm assuming you're white German,
right?
And you're like,
yeah,
that guy,
he's a fucking moron.
You know what I mean?
You're just looking at him like he joined a stupid club despite the fact that
those people can do some really horrific shit too.
So,
um,
but I don't think,
okay,
you know,
you're a bad person for becoming more cautious.
Um,
but I would also remain open minded that this is going to be some really great
people that were lucky enough to get out of those bad situations.
And that's the hard part.
The easy thing is to just say fuck all of these people.
And uh,
you know,
that's,
that's the basic,
let's sit down and eat some fritos and cake.
Um,
or you can actually
do the crunches,
your
cardio and actually try to look at people as individuals.
Now having said that,
when the sun goes down at night,
all bets are Ra.
You have to look at people you know,
the most cautiously,
as cautiously,
as high as you possibly can,
because I guarantee you that even if they had a fucking rule about that during
the day,
if there was a bunch of people walking around,
the,
the chances of them doing that during the day would have been much less.
So,
I'm sorry that happened to one of your cousins.
Uh,
I hope it doesn't turn you into a hateful person.
You seem like you're trying to be measured.
I Dunno,
but it would suck if you became another hateful person because,
uh,
it just going to add fuel to all of this blue tie,
red ties.
Shit.
All right,
dear Billy Butkus
on Valentine's Day,
my ex whom I love people to know how to use whom,
you know,
who and whom.
I'd looked up the definition fucking a hundred times.
I believe I've read it on this podcast.
I still for the life of me cannot figure it out.
Um,
on Valentine's Day,
my ex who I had been dating for three years,
came to my job at a bar with an new much younger day,
sat with her for hours and proceeded to get a cab home with her.
My coworkers obviously told me and I was devastated.
Well,
that's why he did it.
We've been broken up for two and a half months and it was a really tough
breakup.
I know I deserve better,
but I feel like he's driving me out of a small town that I generally love.
This isn't the first time he's a public show with a woman with women.
Um,
at this point I just want to want to move and start over what it should take.
Uh,
my take is that you,
uh,
you're a lucky woman that you,
you,
you didn't hit your wagon to someone that's stead fucking petty.
MMM.
Then yeah,
I don't,
I mean,
I'd like that.
Like,
that's
okay.
I just liked the way you described it.
I look at that guy as though he's pathetic and I feel like,
and I feel bad for the woman that he brought there because I feel like he was
barely listening to her in pretending to be smiling,
having a good time as he was trying to look around to see if he could catch you.
I mean,
he basically went out of his way to hurt you.
We obviously,
when you're,
you,
you're going to break up with somebody that's going to be that awful pain
because usually somebody wants it and the other person doesn't.
So it's bad enough that that went down.
Now if you dumped him,
but I feel like if you dumped him,
you wouldn't be that upset about it.
Um,
and you did say it was really tough.
So,
uh,
what I would say is happy do yourself a celebratory glass of fucking wine,
whatever your poison is that right?
MMM.
You didn't marry this count.
And uh,
I dunno,
I think at some point,
I mean if you really love him,
be ashamed.
If you've,
if you really love living while you were at that you would move just because
some shallow con is bringing some woman that always,
I mean he obviously does not give a fuck about that one cause I,
I'll just tell you this,
if that guy in two and a half months found the one and found true love lists,
petty shit with you would not even be an issue.
So,
okay.
Maybe a new way of looking at it is feeling bad for the woman that he's with.
MMM.
Because he's wasting her time and I,
I could Guaran fucking tee you.
She has no idea who you are and if she does,
then the two fucking psychos that deserve each other,
that should both be sterilized because they're going to make an evil baby.
So there you go.
That's what you walked away from.
Um,
but as far as like,
you know,
at this point you want to move and start over at all,
depends on what you got going on in your town.
That's a pretty a big move.
Uh,
you know what a few days go by.
See if you feel that again,
it just,
I don't know,
just really focused on the type of person that would do something like that.
So to really just go out of your way to hurt somebody and I said,
I've heard a bunch of people in my life but to like go out of your fucking way.
Like that's like the debts,
like the difference between first degree and second degree continuous there,
whereas,
you know,
second degree it's just spontaneously happens.
You know,
you guys got all this history and he just says something fucking horrible or
stuff's chatting up some shit there at the bar,
but to fucking sit there and like methodically plan it out like that,
that guy's a fucking psycho.
And again,
congratulations to you that he's done in your fucking life anymore.
Um,
yeah.
And don't fuck with this food.
That's a petty thing too.
That's bad.
Con,
fuck all that.
All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Thank you to everybody for listening.
And um,
thank you for the writer's guild for letting me be a presenter.
Actually.
Really had a good time once,
once I got,
once I got out there,
I had a good time.
But other than that I was like freaking out.
Like what the fuck am I doing here?
And also please check out my youtube page.
Like I said,
I'm really going to start posting videos and all that shit up there.
Uh,
maybe it'll take a couple of,
I'll do a video of something that the Patrice O'Neil,
um,
comedy benefit,
some backstage shit or something like that.
Um,
and once again,
we'll youtube pages,
youtube.com/user/monday morning podcast.
And as always,
if you'd like to donate to this podcast,
anytime you get a buy some shit,
you don't need an on Amazon,
uh,
just go to my website,
[inaudible] dot com click on the podcast page,
you'll see the Amazon link.
You Click on that,
it takes you there.
I get credit for driving traffic there.
Whatever you buy doesn't cost you any extra money,
amount of money,
and they kicked me a little bit of cash for allegedly driving traffic,
but you are going to fucking go there anyways.
If you want to do it.
Cool.
If not,
I get it.
Alright.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll check it on.
Yeah.
On,
uh,
on Thursday.